a given holding chamber initially
contains 50 cubic feet of unchlorinated
water a 1 gallon chlorine solution
container is accidentally dropped and
the full container spills into the
chamber releasing an unknown amount of
sodium chloride it is mixed and
discharged from the chamber where
measurements determine the sodium
chloride concentration at the discharge
point is now 2.5 milligrams per liter as
chloride what was the concentration of
sodium chloride in milligrams per liter
in the initial chlorine solution
container assume no reactions had
occurred yet at the point in time in
which the measurements were
taken so this is a classic example of a
mass balance problem I didn't even find
a reference to the required equation in
the reference manual uh the closest I
found was on page 460 and even then it
is not identical however this is a
fundamental problem given in
environmental engineering and Water
Resources classes so let's write out the
first
equation the equation we need is going
to be V1 *
C1 plus V2 *
C2 equals
V3 *
C3 V3 can also be written as
V1 plus V2
so let's write out our known
next V1 is going to be the volume in the
holding chamber of unchlorinated water
so that's
50 cubic
feet V2 is going to be the volume of the
chlorine solution container and that's 1
gallon V3 is simply going to be the sum
of both of
those but we can't sum them yet because
their units are not equal so let's hold
off on that for a
second now for our
concentrations C1 is unchlorinated water
so the corresponding amount of chloride
concentration in the holding chamber
initially is going to be zero and let's
write that as mg per
liter we also don't know what the
concentration of sodium chloride is in
the chlorine solution
container so
C2 is going to be what we're solving for
since that's what the problem asks us as
well and finally we see that C3 we do
know that is the concentration of sodium
chlorine at the discharge point and that
was given as
2.5 mg per
liter so originally it might look like
we need to convert all of our volumes
into
liters but it isn't necessary for us to
do that since our units with this
equation here will still cancel out and
leave us with what we need at the end it
would also take more time to convert all
of the volumes into liters instead let's
just convert V1 into gallons since it's
already in that
unit so V1 is going to be
50 cubic feet times our unit conversion
shows us
that there are
7.48
gallons in 1 cubic foot so 50 * 7.48 is
going to give us about
gallons so writing out this equation
with all of our known filled in is going
to
be
374 gal times 0 millgram per
liter
plus
gallon time
x
equals 374 and 1 is going to be
375 and that's going to be gallons
times
2.5 millgram per
liter so what we can see is that this is
a basic mass balance problem and one of
the terms is already going to go away
since there's no chlorine in the first
Chamber from here all we're doing is
multiplying this together and dividing
by one
so X is going to be equal
to
9375 MGR per liter since gallons here
will cancel out and the closest number
we have over here is
950 so again this is a basic problem um
using mass balance principles and it's
important to know this equation in some
form or another I'm not sure I would say
there's a specific one in the book but
the closest you'll get to might be on
page 460 in the reference manual
otherwise it just requires a quick unit
conversion and that's all you need to do
before you solve the problem solve the
equation itself and that's
it